les bienfaits du compost pour nourrir le
sol sont aujourd'hui bien connus mais
depuis quelques années au québec une
poignée d'agriculteurs lutte contre les
insectes les champignons et les
bactéries grâce au thé de compost un
liquide à ne pas boire qui met les
microorganismes du sol au travail
[Musique]
le thé de compost ça fait déjà plusieurs
années qu'on le pratique qu'on en fait
c'était intéressant pour nous parce que
on a un sol très très sablonneux c'est
difficile de protéger notre activité
biologique dans ce soldat qui veut c'est
chez trop vite quand tu fais un peu sec
agronome professeur est désormais
maraîchère andré deschênes a eu
plusieurs
installé depuis 21 ans dans le
kamouraska au jardin des pèlerins elle
est la première productrice à avoir
utilisé le thé de compost au québec dans
une des premières raisons quand on avait
commencé à faire le thé de compost cité
pour les arbres fruitiers
quand les armes sont petits on n'a pas
trop le temps de mettre autant de soin
de choc que ça dessus mais on disait il
faut quand même les renforcer un peu
puis le titre compost atteindre
essentiellement pour des plantes
annuelles qui ont besoin d'être au début
surtout le titre compost c'est de l'eau
dans laquelle on a infusé un compost
pour y multiplier les micro-organismes
vivants et enrichir les sols
au début les gens pensent que c'est pour
extraire des nutriments du compost c'est
pas tout à fait ça ce qu'on veut
extraire du compost ce sont plutôt des
organismes alors on veut extraire du
compost des bactéries des champignons
des protozoaires c'est une sorte
d'inoculation finalement sont les
organismes utiles et qui vont faire
augmenter l'activité biologique
[Musique]
andré deschênes a appris le
fonctionnement et les bienfaits du thé
de compost par l'expérience mais aussi
auprès d'une chercheuse américaine ellen
et nigam microbiologiste et ici au
québec
vivienne cas look si l'os est la
spécialiste du thé de compost pour la
régénération des sols l'été compost ce
qui était intéressant c'est que les
microbes sont menées dans la profondeur
d'une seule à travers de l'eau alors
pilat les microbes sont capables d'aller
au tour des racines des plantes puis
c'est là où est ce qu'on a besoin
les seuls en la matière organique et
raison les minéraux elles sont les
éléments nutritifs que les plantes ont
besoin ça une bonne vie microbienne en
équilibre laplante n'a pas accès à cette
nourrice earl l'utilisation du thé
compost est encore très marginale au
québec mais une poignée de producteurs
et productrices utilisent cette infusion
nouveau genre dans leur culture
gates henry terre fait partie de ces
attaques
je n'avais pas conscience aucune
conscience que sur des feuilles
partout il y avait une micro flaran des
micros gagner ce n'est pas tout droit et
vif
logicom compris le coeur julie tu es en
méthane est d'aider des pesticides
j'étais tellement convaincu à sogeti
phone house tout méchant mais me
framboise mes fraises de l'un des mes
fraises 2-1 de production alors je me
suis mis à faire chaud ce qu'ils font
avec le thé compost aussi ce qu'on peut
pas faire avec le compost c'est que on
peut et prendre sur la surface des
plantes en polarisation foliaire ce
qu'on recherche c'est bien courir la
feuille avec ces organismes-là utile de
façon à ce que les étudiants qui vont
être émis par la feuille soient utilisés
à ces organismes là pour se multiplier
la surface ce qui fait que quand le
pathogène arrive pour lui aussi obtenir
cette belle nourriture la place est
occupée
il ya déjà beaucoup moins de
possibilités d'infection pour les
organismes vont vouloir infecté
l'appelant et les résultats sont au
rendez-vous des temps nous disent plus
de fongicides
il n'a aucune maladie dans les champs
arrosé de thé de compost
alors que la pourriture des fraises
apparaissait dans les parcelles témoins
andré deschênes
elle applique désormais son thé de
compost au sol pour augmenter l'activité
biologique et comme gaëtan elle constate
son efficacité ici contre les chenilles
ou autres parasites
on le met avec une pompe et un boyau
tout simplement
puis on fait un arrosage assez abondants
mais en mettant au sol tout ce qui est
les généralistes dont les pucerons les
acariens et cetera on n'a pas ces
problèmes là du tout parce que si on a
de l'activité biologique au sol tout ça
on n'a même pas besoin d'y penser
d'après toutes ces observations un champ
où on sert le thé de compost améliorer
la croissance des plantes la protection
contre les maladies et la santé des sols
des résultats similaires ont été obtenus
lors des ces scientifiques comme à
l'université laval ou encore en asie ou
en europe
[Musique]
un des avantages notoires de cette
approche est de diminuer les intrants en
fongicides pesticides voire même en
engrais on protège nos plantes on les
rend plus forte fait qu'il ya beaucoup
moins de risques de l'autre heures
d'avoir besoin d'autres choses aussi
heureux propriétaires de la ferme
familiale mélanie brouillard teste de
nouvelles pratiques
agroenvironnementales depuis quelques
années déjà dans sa ferme de grandes
cultures dites conventionnelles
audacieuse et déterminée elle étonnée
déjà en utilisant du compost au lieu de
son fumier et cette année elle a
transformé un ancien réservoir aller en
théière géante pour qu'on passe on est à
notre deuxième année d'essai et autres
journées modifications à faire des
ajustements
puis
c'est ça on vend suit l'évolution l'eau
s'améliore d'année en année l'eau avec
notre pulvérisateurs ont fait une partie
de chant puis on laisse une partie qui
est pas appliquée on n'a pas fait
d'applications fait qu'on peut comparer
malefoy ce concept un c'est que notre
pays va être belle encore une année de
plus c'est ça je dirais on a atteint un
bon
un bon point notion pourrait avoir notre
notre usine notre f
une année supplémentaire qu'à l'habitude
mais ça ce serait des jo un plus pour
obtenir un bon thé de compost gorgé de
micro-organismes bénéfique
il y à quelques étapes importantes à
respecter avec une base de compost
on peut faire beaucoup des compos ce
dépendamment est ce qu'on a besoin aux
chaînes on va faire notre recette en
conséquence
mais la première étape s'est fabriqué
son appareil après on de trouver noté
noc l'homme un bon compost
puis on est dans des filtres pour qu'ils
se rattraper dans l'eau pour que soient
bien accueillis janyk pour les relations
puis on laisse 36 48 heures jusqu'à
temps que le vix souhaité développer
on ne veut pas des pathogènes et les les
organismes qu'on veut son aérobie
presque tous les pathogènes sont à
naïrobi on veut surtout pas se retrouver
à naïrobi ce que de manquer d'air
il faut aussi ajouter de la nourriture
pour aider les micro-organismes à se
multiplier et il ne faut pas les
détruire lors de l'application
c'est toute une recette faut vérifier il
était compost le compost et faire le
suivi dans l'essonne avant puis après
après les applications pour voir qu'est
ce que ça donne est ce qu'il ya des
agissements faire et cetera
comme l'an dernier mélanie brouillard
rencontre viviane cas look si l'os pour
vérifier les micro organismes présents
dans son compost sont et compost et dans
son sol avant et après l'application
pour les nématodes dans ce style d'
analyse c'est mieux de regarder
plusieurs gotta principalement je
regarde qui est là qu elle sorte vie
microbienne est présente dans le système
je cherche aussi la présence des
organismes qui sont moins idéal dans les
écosystèmes le seul qui ait beaucoup
plus de travail fait par des
micro-organismes nous on économise du
temps beaucoup et ça pour nous c'est
vraiment être le facteur le plus
important dans les grands bénéfices du
décompose ça offre aussi une belle
manière de produire la nourriture de
plus en plus dans une manière bio est
saine